lors du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
gilles lurton
merci merci monsieur le président la
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des affaires sociales
madame la ministre au cours de la
discussion parlementaire sur le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
nous vous avons demandé d'inscrire dans
la loi le versement de la prime de
naissance avant l'arrivée de l'enfant
alors que depuis l'année dernière vous
avez décidé qu'elle ne serait versée que
trois mois après la naissance
cette prime d'un montant de 923 euros
non revalorisé en 2015 permet aux
familles notamment les plus modestes
l'achat des équipements indispensables à
l'anglais borgata nous fait hélas tous
ici nous savons que la majorité des
familles possèdent à ses achats avant
l'arrivée de l'enfant
or depuis votre décision force est de
constater que la filière puériculture a
vu très significativement son activité
reculer en 2015
j'ajoute que les derniers chiffres
démographiques de l'insee montrent un
recul important de la natalité dans
notre pays nous vous avons alerté à
maintes reprises sur les conséquences
désastreuses de votre politique
familiale réduction de plus de 300 euros
du quotient familial réduction et
modulation en fonction des ressources de
la prestation d'accueil du jeune enfant
et enfin en 2014 modulation du montant
des allocations familiales c'est au bas
mot 8 millions d'euros au que vous avez
retiré aux familles
face à cette baisse de la natalité nous
devons tout mettre en oeuvre pour
faciliter aux parents
l'arrivée d'un enfant ma proposition sur
la prime de naissance peut être d'effet
immédiat madame la ministre vous m'avez
répondu que cela ne relevait pas de la
loi mais d'un décret alors
envisagez-vous de signer ce décret et
permettre ainsi aux parents de percevoir
la prime de naissance avant l'arrivée de
leur enfant
merci
la parole est à madame laurence
rossignol secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille de l'enfance et des personnes
âgées de l'autonomie monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député gilles lurton
lorsque le président de la république à
engager la france dans le redressement
de ses comptes publics ce qui je crois
nous rassemble tous ici écouter la
réponse à une question du redressement
productif et du redressement économique
la branche à gaston familiale qui à
l'époque accusé un déficit de plus de
deux milliards et demi d'euros a été
également appelés à contribuer au
redressement des comptes publics
la prime de naissance que vous évoquez
est versée pour chaque naissance pour
chaque enfant
le premier le deuxième de troisième elle
se répète à chaque enfant pour des
dépenses qui parfois elle ne se répète
pas mais le choix que nous avons fait
c'est de continuer de verser la prime de
naissance pour chaque naissance
nous avons cependant opéré un décalage
elle n'est plus versé au septième mois
de grossesse mais dans les deux mois au
deuxième mois de la naissance de
l'enfant
cette mesure que nous avons prises
aujourd'hui et elle est étudiée par les
caisses d'allocations familiales avec
bienveillance et justice sociale puisque
une instruction a été donnée par le
conseil d'administration de verser aux
familles les plus vulnérables
la prise de naissance en avance et ceci
dès le septième mois
c'est une avance qui est versée aux
familles qui évite justement que un
certain nombre de dessins dépenses ne
puisse pas est assumée par ailleurs
cette prime de naissance est versée à 85
% des familles toutes ne sont pas des
familles vulnérables
elle s'inscrit dans une politique de
redressement des comptes publics et
surtout une politique de la famille
ambitieuse qui permet aujourd'hui à la
france de continuer d'avoir un fort taux
d'activité professionnelle des femmes un
taux de natalité qui est un plus élevés
d'europe et qui garantit la l'engagement
du gouvernement auprès de toutes les
familles y compris les plus vulnérables